- All right, before we go,
I have one last awesome gem I
found, scrolling social media.
You're welcome in advance.
This is What I'm Liking.
(bold music)
(audience cheering)
As mamas, our jobs are to raise our kids
to do the right thing,
what we feel is right.
So when one Virginia Beach mama found out
her 16-year-old son tipped a server less
than 10%, she told him what was up.
Check this out.
- [Danielle] Johnny, you
need to go get my wallet.
You need to go get my Visa card.
You need to go to the ATM and you need
to go grab a 20 and drive your (beep) back
to that restaurant,
because on a $104 check,
$10 is a (beep) tip.
Do you understand me?
Go grab my credit card, get
$20 and drive it back there.
Yes ma'am.
- [Johnny] Yes ma'am.
(audience cheering and applauding)
- She said, "Yes ma'am."
We have that mama, Danielle
on the line right now,
along with her son, Johnny.
I'm so sorry, Johnny (laughs).
(audience applauding)
So, Danielle.
- Hi, how are you?
- You seem pretty worked up in the video.
You sound like you were maybe, a server.
I was a server, were you?
- Yes, I was a server (chuckles).
- So you get it, you get it, man.
You survive off those tips.
So do you usually go off
on him for not tipping?
This is amazing.
- Yes, I usually go off on him (laughs).
We have that relationship,
I guess (laughs).
- No, I love it.
It's honest
and also, it's teaching him
what is the norm, right?
So Johnny, were you surprised
by your mom's reaction?
- In the beginning, yeah.
But, she's from Jersey,
so she's kinda like that.
(audience laughing)
I learned my lesson now.
- Yes you did.
- He is definitely gonna
do that 10%, Danielle.
Oh, my gosh, well, I love it.
I think it's so important too
because if you have been a server,
you realize those tips really do count.
So thank you for going back, Johnny.
That was very cool to
do to for the server.
And thank you, Danielle,
for teaching your boy how
to do it right.
I'm liking your post right now, all right?
(audience applauding)
- [Danielle] All right, thank you.
- All right, but that's not all.
Our season-long partner,
Pilot Pen, makers of G2,
the go-to pen of the
Kelly Clarkson Show, love
that you're looking out for people
in the service industry.
So they're gonna be writing
you a check for $1,000.
How's that sound?
(audience cheering)
(Kelly chuckling)
Thank you guys so much,
you are a funny family.
Thank you to all our guests this hour,
Ben Affleck, Mat Damon,
Chris Tucker, Skylar Vann,
the whole Oklahoma Women's Basketball Team
and Lawrence Zarian,
y'all have a great day.
If it's not, try and change it.